so guys it's lovely to see you here with
your film whiplash which is brilliant by
the way you play father and son in it
how did you get that on-screen chemistry
oh
you know we just paul's just one of
those the guys he's just he's a very
his father figure
figurally brother he's very father
figure and i you know for me it was easy
because i grew up watching miles tell
the movies and my parents used to take
me to see his movies and so i i knew him
as a person it was they're in black and
white so it must been weird the first
time you saw me in color yeah no that
wasn't right and uh
actually and miles is not that much
older than my own sons so uh it was very
it was very easy to relate and uh
it's a great it's a great powerful movie
and it's and it's hard to explain to
people why it's so powerful because you
hear about it it's a guy plays the drums
and his teacher is mean to him how is
that exciting and it's it's unbelievably
compelling his drumming is great his
performance is terrific it's really it's
an unbelievable movie you mentioned the
drumming there how was it getting
prepared for that role how much practice
did you have to do and were you into
jazz before this film i i played
saxophone in jazz band when i was in
high school for a little bit and then i
i played drums from by the time i was 15
i played a couple rock bands
but never really drum jazz and probably
because because it was so yeah because
it was so daunting to me the jazz
drumming is is very hard it's very
difficult and so i was very i was
nervous damian sent me the tracks and
you know the stuff that i was going to
have to play and and i
would have felt pretty foolish if i was
just you know
uh
if i was so far off from where i had to
be so i practiced four hours a lesson a
couple lessons a week for a couple weeks
and i had no idea when i saw the film i
turned and i i thought they were going
to fake it yeah and it was like 98 him
actually playing and just going wow it's
fantastic the other 2 is paul
i was proud as his fake father of his
fake drumming
i mean god it's really blood sweating
here from this movie quite literally
isn't it i mean
how hard was it doing it for real that
drumming because obviously you mean
you've got the bloodiness going on
you're sweating those drum solos are
pretty
harsh aren't they i think it's pretty
exhausting when you film a movie in 19
days you're doing you know at least five
pages a day
and a lot of those you know it doesn't
take much space on a page to say andrew
drums like crazy so yeah i mean you do
this for long enough and your forearm
will
burn you spent many years alone doing
that right well i used to uh so you
built up a lot of muscle well i mean i
used to i well you know i tossed salads
for living at that restaurant so i was
always shaking the dressing shaking the
dressing shaking the dressing shaking
the dressing and it was very fruitful
yes
i'm glad to hear you had a lot of
practice time beforehand so very worked
well for you guys now in the film you
have a lot of different inspirations
like there's betty rich mentioned there
there's also charlie parker and i
wondered who
your guys who your inspirations were as
actors i never knew as a kid that i
wanted to be an actor i remember the
first actor that i fell in love with was
peter falk and i just thought i don't
even know what this guy's doing but it's
different than anything i've ever seen
it's funny it's moving and uh and i got
to work with him years later so it was
kind of a dream come true who did you
watch
uh
wizard of oz i watched as a very little
kid and i i just that was a magical time
for me that's a lot of you know
i wanted to be
i wanted to be the uh judy garland's
shoes i just liked her shoes
but no i mean i love tom hanks and i
love phillip seymour hoffman and
daniel day lewis and leo and you know
there's a lot of there's you're
constantly being humbled by
great great actors christopher bale and
so it's a uh you know it's a
never-ending you're always just kind of
going back and realizing there's a lot
of people much better than you and if
you want to hang around you better put
the work in yeah absolutely and you
certainly are i can see i mean in the
film your character really puts himself
through the ringer doesn't he to to do
what he does to be a great drummer he
wants to be one of the greats not just
any old drummer i wondered how far you
guys would go for a partner for acting
i think it's pretty clear we're not
reaching that high yeah
when you say
there's a certain level and you go i
remember you said to me you know what
this is i think that's what's directly
offered to you right
i said you have to be good he said yeah
it's not for me
i had a couple free weeks in september
i mean there you hear about it all the
time actors i've i've bombed and
auditioned and begged for another one
and then got in the movie just out of
determination
you'll find do you find when you after
an audition and you do this do it to
yourself in the car you do the same
scene in the car you're fantastic i'm
fantastic in my car
yeah after i ever dropped a fantastic
car yeah no after when after i after i
blow an audition i get in the car oh if
they had seen me i need a small space
well they say what after there's three
scenes there's the way you want to do it
the way you do it the way you do it and
then the way you wish you did it yeah
exactly yeah well the thing is you can
do things so differently can't you and
finally just a wrapper what are you guys
going to be doing next now i know miles
first off you've got insurgent and
divergent coming up how many huge huge
big movies that everyone's looking
forward to yeah well like you said i'm
going to become a pretty big movie star
here in the next few months yeah yeah
yeah one of the greats like in the film
yeah i'll become one of the one of the
greats am i in these movies
the ones that are you doing well i told
you i'd never worked with you again no i
know but i i thought you were kidding
yeah really not wow so that awkward
moment comes out january 31st that's
romantic comedy a little lighter and
then i've got divergent this summer and
some other stuff i'm working on but
you'll find out about it
i'm actually going to know i did two
movies this summer
like back did this one another one
called life after beth which is
premiering at sundance
and uh and i'm gonna do a movie called
beg the devil which is a shooting in
april which is uh with uh peter dinklage
and michael shannon and the really fun
really cool movie wow
fantastic i look forward to seeing both
those movies i'm sure people are going
to really enjoy whiplash when they get
to see it as well thank you
you